all right what's your folks are e trying
to fight even though he started what so
everyone's favored a Kanye song Oh baby
rich I would say this pockets probably
at i/o is so many mink blink in Paris oh
yeah so not fair we can't even actually
say the name and Sun would call just
Paris right I like all the songs in the
vh1 storytellers one so though the
Curtis may feel one is this guy yeah and
then there's the other one that's uh
what's the one that makes you feel happy
touch this guy there's another one that
make you feel happy golden Denton
thousand now that makes me want to go
lift some weight through the wire knows
that was just hit single that put him on
the map right through the wire Jesus
walk jesus walks that thing really put
him on a man wears gold diggers BAM
yeah hey man Jamie Foxx
I like that more because of the Joe
Rogan interview with Jamie Foxx him time
to story about how was the story
basically he was at a party and then he
gave him that song was it all we should
work together and usually whatever and
then he gives him all that good lyrics
and then he want to sing a solo soulful
because I guess that's like his
background in singing then Kanye West
like now you guys do like this and he
was just like man [ __ ] that so he just
does it and then he goes off to shoot a
movie in he was about Bayes like I was a
stupid song you know he gets back from
the movie his homie was like yo that
song he said that was like whatever is
the number one song in America oh that's
tight yeah that means Kanye West was was
smarter than Jamie yeah yeah fast can
see what Kanye saw no yeah we also
didn't do do it how Tanya wanted him do
it right no so he like Kanye have this
song and be like do it everywhere you
want to do it yeah cuz uh Jamie Foxx
want to do his parts like in a soul full
way I don't three-self but no but then a
month again then
the way he says like he actually wanted
to do it Oh Logan he was like super
singing and he was like not let's do
like that and he was like [ __ ] it all
right
they you don't know what you're talking
about so then that's why I like the song
now that's yeah man
with Kanye I got love his music so much
and like a lot of respect his artistry
so much but [ __ ] man I hate the fact
that he gets into news for all he's
learning Kim's his wife is a master Rose
in the news for wifey miss Kim's that's
not true well he's not exactly in the
news per se but his bodyguard his former
bodyguard I did an interview recently
and he basically put Kanye on blast this
is supposed to sign an NDA and I say
[ __ ] guess the NDA does it not work when
you quit I guess I don't know but if I
was in the industry I'm like I'm never
gonna hire that guy like if this guy is
talking [ __ ] about that guy if I hire
him where is this guy gonna say about me
true
maybe the industry paid him to spill
some tea maybe Kanye paid him to spill
some tea some tea about Kanye the key is
this guy saying out of all the
celebrities he's ever been a bodyguard
for and this includes like Leonardo
DiCaprio freakin um well when are
DiCaprio a-listers right okay we're the
fight so many [ __ ] pictures is when
you find like pro bodyguards that all
the celebrities can borrow I don't know
Matt Damon Ben Affleck Stephen Baldwin
Woody Harrelson told you like that guy I
like that guy too and then they [ __ ]
share this that guy had enough time to
bodyguard all of them right sometimes
they hire you for so enjoy eggs just
like specific gig like award shows or
what what if you don't network while
you're there yes
you don't treat you know you don't you
don't build rapport it's like who is
this guy in my club exactly right
because like if I was a celebrity and I
was hiring a bodyguard I would want the
guy to know me in and out and like to
know exactly what I like and sir
of like where I go how I want to move
you know where I want to park all these
things and if you keep switching them
out it's just and you have to keep you
learning this person's like energy I
don't know I'm big sometimes when I
think they go into a city they want a
body bar from that city because that
person knows the city so first it's like
a bodyguard that goes with you like say
Turturro know you might know everything
about you
but in Toronto it's like both you guys
are just as lost so I know some people
they like if they land in LA they like
that Elvie guy yeah cuz that get them
all the clubs do all these things cuz
they're not just protection it's also
like just smoothness and efficiency of
travel in that city too when we went to
Toronto we had bodyguards and the news
like the city's so well so like those
two cars in each one was there also the
drivers so they're like they did not
give a [ __ ] about traffic lights and I
couldn't [ __ ] about Iran red light in a
safe way like if say one made it and the
other one was still behind he was going
no matter what and then they had like
they had signals with how they honked
how they push people but like so what
happens when they get pulled over I
don't know they literally double parking
places I was like super crowded games
and like it was like one of those like
the maple Eve hockey games and I was
like well what if their car gets towed
total some of these guys are also a
farmer or law enforcement and they're
buddies with the whole department too
so they know oh that's Richard's car
yeah there's there's bees working those
people that are just really connected
he's guarding the mayor yeah yeah so
with this guy he's saying Kanye was
probably the hardest person he's ever
had to guard he that Kanye's rules was
to have this guy stand behind him ten
paces back what if someone wants to
because he's and that's the bodyguards
point he's like how the [ __ ] am I
supposed to [ __ ] protect you if I'm
already ten paces back from you you know
and that's just the beginning of it on
the first day that they meant and they
met in an inside an elevator
Steve savages his name Steve David W
Ressler
I know who also used to perform for the
Chippendales oh she's a stripper and a
bottom bodyguard that's right that's
been fun picture on the be like [ __ ]
big and Jack this [ __ ] anyways they
might as well true
that makes sense yeah so good get into
the elevator right look use your body
and the bodyguards just standing there
inside the elevator and kinase like dude
you're not gonna press the elevator
button what's up with that
and he's like well I don't sir I don't
know where you want to go and then he's
like
kinds like so you mean you didn't call
ahead to find out where I'm supposed to
be going then and then he's like no it's
my first day I'm meeting you right now
and then and then and they keep going
back and forth about what button to
press on the elevator
cuz Connie doesn't know he does not know
and the bodyguards like bro like what
hit all the buttons [ __ ] it you can tell
me what button to press and now I'll
know - you could press the button and
I'll see which one you're pressing and
then I'll know or three you can sit here
all day and tell me how important is and
where we are not gonna be going anywhere
at all or D I could beat your ass for
more money exactly true and and so then
that's kind of like how the Kanye
operates it's like she doesn't give you
a whole lot and he just kind of leaves
you in the dark and expects to do
everything yeah and and that's kind of
like I get that a little bit so she was
that big you want if you come from data
right I'm sure he's had other bodyguards
that were trained like that he needs a
better assistant or whatever to deal
with that because then you don't have to
teach them on how to do things you just
hire them for you know it's not Kanye's
job yeah it's it's supposed to be the
people that organizes his life no you
should yell at them true but then like a
certain point though if you say they get
this party guards saying like every
conversation I ever had with Kanye ended
up with the whole one twos and threes
and he quotes that like I give him the
one-two and threes scenario ed you tell
me this they're gonna be you do it and
I'll follow suit in the future or three
we just keep talking about it here and
not do nothing right and he says every
conversation with Kanye and the buddy in
that way yeah well you never learned to
call him I don't know maybe that's why
cuz if any of one of them will give a
little bit more they would avoid the
issue so if Kanye was like okay I'll
help this guy a little bit
it could avoid that or if that guy was
like alright [ __ ] I'm not gonna talk
carnie I'll just talk to him hey manager
okay get your number I'll talk to you
direct write both didn't want a budge
they both had egos
it's like if each one like okay okay I
don't know either hold on let's let's
talk to your manager
what floor we're supposed to be on oh no
all right Jeff thank you to park until
like somebody came in right kanya you
still here actually met at the elevator
they walked in and I mean had nowhere to
go yes all right
so what's up buddy the funny thing is
Connie didn't fire him after that he
kept oh he kept in for a little bit yes
yeah and then and then this guy goes on
to say and this is kind of what we were
talking about in the beginning this guy
thinks that Kanye and Kim definitely
call ahead for the paparazzi all of
those known mm-hmm that's like good that
what everyone talks about you think so
yeah they're like hey I'm gonna be at
this spot like they work together so
they could get those like yeah it's a
common thing where they're coming out
with a new album or something and they
want publicity that's why people act
like the paparazzi is so annoying but
it's like this ecosystem that needs to
happen they mean to leak out [ __ ] for
them to get publicity for them to get
drama pay relevant yeah it all works out
yeah oh they did an interview look I
figure on Jubilee and they interviewed
all these like paparazzi's in like the
one that they like oh do you disagree
and like so all these people that are
like oh we're invading their lives who's
like you know how many celebrities I
have that call me like am a bit of the
spot right now and when you smash the
cameras do they actually in fact pay
them back and thanks for letting me
smash your cameras you know a big circus
I think for that then there's obviously
certain cases where they don't want to
be found call you this time yeah I told
you to smash the camera my left hand
that's the cheap one expensive one just
like that the famous one with Kanye I
think I was like it could work honey
shut the [ __ ] up what they're like on
his driveway and he's like in the garage
damn can I just get a license to kill
instead of body art that would be way
cooler that would be pretty cool yeah
but I don't know I don't think my life
is threatened I know what circumstances
would it require the license to kill in
your opinion like yeah that's completely
different from having a body and
to kill someone for you to have a
bodyguard right you could just kill them
already because they're they're trying
to kill you
so it's self-defense it's all talk yeah
but what if like I just want to kill
that guy and what is light license to
kill II mean to you it's like the keys
to the city
mmm you just get to shoot whoever you
want like a samurai mmm samurais hot
people they snap it yeah yeah so it's
just a license he's nice yeah so it's
like you're you're the executioner and
the judge at the same time like judge
Judge Dredd oh it just sounds like a
good adventure I didn't really think it
through what's a good reason they kill
someone's feelings
yeah you still any any negative feelings
you're like a license to happy to sad
curiosity killed the cat you're gonna
get a lot of fake people around you that
are too scared to piss you off and then
that's better
oh you'll have a Penta casts friend
would you rather have all ten authentic
friends that talk [ __ ] to you make you
feel bad or a bunch of liars and keep
you happy
like Kanye hmm exactly
or you could fake your death in the
whole world thinks that you just died of
a [ __ ] heart attack but in reality
you're just fishing out all the bad guys
that were fake friends within your
company guess who that was kim
jeong-hoon what would you do like if you
faked your death and how would you get
mad like people didn't post like RPG on
their social media yeah go backfire plan
backfired yeah there you didn't take
over my regime and take all my facebook
citizen didn't even die
no no what he saw you faked his death to
fish out all the people that were
plotting against him within his
government official now that he's still
alive he's alive windows first
two weeks ago yeah he came out oh [ __ ] I
don't wash my hair
since the beginning to south Kobe he's
been hiding for years then no he was it
[Music]
everybody was just came back everyone
thought Kim jong-un died because there
were rumors that he went into a hospital
and he stayed in surgery for a while he
has health problems
there were heart surgeons that went from
China to confirm and all this stuff and
what he was doing is he created this to
fish out who would immediately start to
plot against him after they thought you
and did he catch people we'll see we'll
find out I mean that's one of the
reasons why he murdered his uncle nobody
talk [ __ ] he's like yeah thank you were
gonna duck [ __ ] oh yeah ends up everyone
loves him and he's like okay guys I'm
sorry I have something to confess I was
paranoid and I thought you guys would
all turn on me but in reality you guys
are some loyal ass [ __ ] I didn't feel
was like that and they become a happier
family no North Korean drop in thirty
countries but Doug said my coffee was
bad so he's gonna die but aside from you
[Music]
[Music]